vamos a considerar ve un sub espacio
vectorial nuevamente y vamos a suponer
que es el conjunto de todos los vectores
digamos que sean x 1 x 2 x 3 todos
aquellos vectores de este tipo de
coordenadas pero que además satisfacen
una expresión que tenemos que voy a
apuntar en unos momentos que satisfacen
que x1 + x2 más x 3 es igual a 0 es
decir que si sumamos las coordenadas de
este vector entonces la suma de todas
sus coordenadas me debe dar 0 y como en
el vídeo anterior
estamos buscando encontrar quién es o
cómo está definida la proyección sobre
el sub espacio b de cualquier vector x
que se encuentra en rn ahora bien si
tomamos esto si tomamos este sub espacio
b que ya vemos que es un plano en r3 lo
que vamos a hacer es despejar la x 1 y
tratar de parametrizar lo entonces
tenemos que x 1 será igual a
2 x 2 - x 3 y ahora lo que podemos hacer
es justamente la parte de la
parametrización digamos que x 2 es igual
a cierto número c 2 y que x 3
déjenme déjenme hacerlo con verde
vamos a seguir haciéndolo con verde
digamos que x2 es cierto número dos y
que x 3 es cierto número 3 el mismo
truquito de la parametrización que
siempre hemos hecho
entonces esto de acá arriba ya no es x2
aquí es de 2 este es de 3 y por lo tanto
x 1 lo podemos reescribir como x 1 es
menos co2 menos 3 donde por supuesto x 2
o más bien c2 y c3 son cualesquiera
números reales entonces vamos a
reescribir esto porque tendremos que el
sub espacio b será el conjunto de los x
1 x 2 x 3
tales que sean de la siguiente forma
fíjense
xy si multiplicamos primero por cerdos
por cerdos quienes tienen hace dos a x1
que tiene aquí un -1 ok a x2 que tiene
un 1 y x 3 no tiene hace 2 entonces le
ponemos un 0 muy bien y además vamos a
tener que sumar vamos a tener que sumar
un c3 es verdad se 3 x 1 tiene un menos
111 3 - 1 y se x2 no tiene hace 3 esto
es 0 y x 3 si tiene hace 13 es un 1 de
hecho ok y este es este es nuestro psuv
espacio que no es otra cosa más que si
nos damos cuenta aquí estamos
multiplicando por todos los valores
posibles al menos 110 y al menos 101
entonces esto nos está diciendo que ve
es el espacio vectorial generado por
estos dos vectores por el vector menos
110 y por el vector menos 10
ok entonces tenemos este espacio
vectorial generado y podemos utilizar
exactamente lo mismo que vimos antes
podemos construir nuestra matriz
de la base y que además por cierto estos
dos son base verdad porque si aquí
tenemos un 1 y aquí tenemos un 0 la
única forma de multiplicar a este para
que nos dé este vector es x 0 pero eso
no es cierto porque menos 1 por 0 me da
0 y no nos da menos 1 entonces estos dos
no son linealmente dependientes de hecho
son linealmente independientes y como
generan al espacio vectorial entonces es
una base y por lo tanto podemos
construir nuestra matriz a verdad la
matriz aquí yo lo había definido como
aquella matriz que tiene como columnas a
la base de nuestro espacio b ok a una
base porque pueden obtener una única
entonces con esta matriz lo que podemos
hacer es definir la proyección la
proyección sobre el sub espacio be de
cualquier vector x de la siguiente forma
como una multiplicación de matrices
sabemos que era a x a transpuesta por a
a la menos 1 x transpuesta que
multiplica a nuestro vector
x ok entonces vamos a buscar ahora otra
forma de poder llegar hasta a conocer
esta matriz de proyección y lo que vamos
a hacer es lo siguiente vamos a irnos a
lo siguiente vamos a tratar de encontrar
una forma más fácil de poder hallar esta
matriz de proyección y eso lo vamos a
hacer de la siguiente forma consideremos
cualquier vector en r3 muy bien esto
inmediatamente me está diciendo sabemos
que x lo puedo descomponer como una suma
de dos vectores de hecho uno ve que este
es el que se encuentra en el sub espacio
vectorial b y un w que se encuentra en
el complemento ortogonal entonces vamos
a escribir eso donde
donde ve está en nuestro psuv espacio
b&w se encuentra en el espacio vector ya
en el complemento ortogonal de este sub
espacio b ok y eso pues lo podemos
reescribir de una sola forma es decir
que x en realidad lo puede escribir como
la suma de la proyección sobre el
espacio b de x más la proyección pero
sobre el sub espacio b ortogonal de x
del complemento ortogonal de x esto
podríamos escribirlo incluso también
matricial mente porque del lado
izquierdo uno tiene la matriz identidad
la matriz identidad y tres de x y tres
de x que será igual a la matriz b
digamos si estamos calculando la
proyección de este x sobre sobre el sub
espacio b entonces esto es alguna matriz
por equis de hecho esta matriz es esta
de aquí verdad
más cierta matriz sé que multiplica a
equis o bien podríamos sí sí sí
factorizar del lado derecho la equis
esto lo podríamos ver como la matriz
identidad de tres por tres que
multiplica x será igual además que
multiplica al vector x muy bien y de
hecho para que esta ecuación pueda darse
a cabo lo que nos corresponde hacer es
ver que la matriz y de entre y identidad
perdón de tres por tres sea igual a una
matriz b más una matriz c
esta expresión nosotros queremos
resolver para ver por qué la matriz be
es la matriz de proyección sobre el sub
espacio b entonces lo que podríamos
pensar es bueno quizás la matriz de
proyección sé que es la matriz de
proyección sobre el complemento
ortogonal quizás sea más fácil de
obtener y entonces que tendríamos si la
c la pasamos restando del lado izquierdo
tendríamos que ver es igual a la matriz
identidad de 3 por 3 menos
y entonces simplemente esto se vuelve
algo muy sencillo de calcular siempre y
cuando sea también sencillo calcular
nuestra matriz ce entonces vamos a
intentarlo déjenme reescribir esto
déjenme reescribir lo que llevamos
déjenme reescribir eso porque tenemos
nuestro sub espacio b que es el conjunto
de todos los vectores x 1 x 2 x 3 tales
que tales que
tales que cumplen esta está esta
propiedad que la suma de todas sus
coordenadas nos de 0 muy bien eso que
nos está diciendo aquí lo que podríamos
expresar es esto porque tenemos digamos
la matriz 111 que podemos hacer una
multiplicación con el vector x 1 x 2 x 3
verdad porque si yo multiplico esto me
queda 1 x x 1 es x 11 x x 12 x 21 x x 3
x 3 y esto debe ser igual a la matriz
que sólo tiene una entrada y que es 0
verdad entonces en realidad nuestro
espacio vectorial ve nuestro espacio
vectorial b es el espacio nulo de una
matriz porque estamos viendo todos
aquellos vectores que al multiplicarlos
por una matriz de hecho es la matriz 1 1
a de multiplicarlos nos da el 0 ok
entonces realmente nuestro espacio
vectorial lo podemos ver como en el es
como el espacio nulo de la matriz 1 1 1
muy bien y vamos a tratar de darle
visualización de esto
vamos a tratar de dar un poco de
visualización yo puedo tener aquí mi
plano
está mi plano
un poquito más grande
es mi plano
ahí está y por supuesto estamos pensando
que se extiende en todas las direcciones
y queremos ver a su complemento
ortogonal vamos a verlo aquí para poder
hacer las proyecciones muy bien este es
el complemento ortogonal y acá se
encuentra ve de hecho quien sería el
complemento ortogonal el complemento
ortogonal sería el complemento ortogonal
es el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz 111
verdad porque b es este espacio nulo y
hay que calcular este ortogonal entonces
realmente si ya está ya sabemos de hace
muchos vídeos que el núcleo o el espacio
nulo de una matriz cuando queremos
calcular el club el complemento
ortogonal eso no es otra cosa más que el
espacio fila o lo que es lo mismo el
espacio columna de nuestra matriz a pero
transpuesta entonces esto que tenemos
aquí no es otra cosa más que el espacio
columna de la matriz transpuesta pero la
matriz transpuesta es simplemente poner
para
adif o al vector muy bien está allá de
pie o lo que es lo mismo es lo mismo que
el espacio columna de un vector es lo
mismo que el espacio vectorial generado
por el vector 111 muy bien y eso es
simplemente porque pues un solo vector
que no es el cero siempre es linealmente
independiente y además pues si genera el
espacio entonces ya tenemos una base
completa para ese para ese espacio
entonces podríamos aplicar lo mismo que
hemos estado aplicando para la matriz a
pero para una nueva matriz que digamos
vamos a llamarla no lo sé vamos a
llamarla la matriz de que no he
utilizado ese nombre que es la que tiene
como columnas a las columnas de la
matriz en este caso sólo es una columna
que es el 1 1 1 ok entonces la
proyección vamos a calcular ahora la
proyección sobre el espacio el sobre el
complemento ortogonal de nuestro sub
espacio b de cualquier vector
y eso como vimos en hace ya dos vídeos y
como hemos visto en el en los ejemplos
anteriores esto es nuestra matriz de que
multiplica de transpuesta x de a todo
eso a la menos 1 que multiplica de
transpuesta y multiplica finalmente a
nuestro vector x entonces qué es lo que
hemos estado haciendo hasta ahorita
tenemos a b1 que es el conjunto de todos
los los vectores que satisfacen esta
está igualdad muy bien entonces nos
interesaba nos interesaba saber cuál es
la proyección de cualquier vector sobre
ese espacio vectorial en particular
entonces esto nos llevó a pensar que
quizás calcular esta multiplicación de
matrices podría ser realmente revoltoso
complicado y demás así que vamos a irnos
lateralmente por otro lado vamos a
tratar de resolver el problema de otra
forma y eso es viendo que si podemos
expresar lo de esta forma llegamos a una
ecuación entre matrices que la identidad
de 3 por 3 es nuestra matriz b más la
matriz c o bien que la matriz que me
interesa que es la b que es la matriz de
proyección sobre el sub espacio b de
nuestro de cualquier vector x es la
matriz identidad de 3 x 3 menos la
matriz de proyección pero sobre el
complemento ortogonal muy bien entonces
vamos a ver esta es la matriz ésta
esta de aquí esta que voy a enmarcar
esta es la matriz la matriz de
transformación
la matriz de transformación muy bien y
que es nuestra matriz sé que queremos
encontrar muy bien y entonces esto debe
ser muy sencillo de calcular porque de
transpuesta de transpuesta es el la
matriz que está acosta la verdad de esta
forma es aquí está de simplemente de
transpuesta es esa misma pero acostada
que hay que multiplicarlo por x por d
del lado derecho es decir hay que hacer
esta multiplicación
lo más derecho esta multiplicación 1
y al hacer esta multiplicación que es lo
que obtenemos pues simplemente vamos a
obtener si tenemos una matriz aquí que
es de 1 x 3 y este es de 3 por 1 pues
simplemente obtenemos una de uno por uno
entonces tenemos este renglón por esta
columna hacemos la multiplicación del
producto escalar y tenemos uno por uno
es hacerlo con este color uno por uno es
1 1 por 1 es 1 así que aquí los sumando
y finalmente uno por uno es 1 y nos
queda la matriz de un único elemento que
es el 3 así que esta expresión que
tenemos aquí no es otra cosa más que de
que es esta matriz 111 que multiplica
esto me quedó bastante feo
es la 111 que multiplica a esta matriz
que encontramos pero inversa es decir
esta matriz la matriz que sólo tiene al
3 pero inversa y que multiplica la
matriz acostada que tiene 111 y
finalmente multiplica al vector x pero
hay que ver hay que recordar muy bien
recordemos muy bien que a la menos 1 por
a es la identidad verdad entonces si yo
tengo la matriz que solo tiene al 3 a la
menos 1 y tengo que multiplicarlo por el
3 y me debe dar la matriz identidad pero
de uno por uno es decir la que tiene
solo al 1 entonces por quien tengo que
multiplicar al 3 para que me dé 1 pues
eso es simplemente la la matriz que
tiene un tercio verdad un tercio por la
matriz que tiene 3 me da la matriz que
sólo tiene 1 entonces esta parte de aquí
no es otra cosa más que la matriz
que solo tiene al un tercio entonces
realmente estamos considerándolo como un
escalar muy bien entonces vamos a ir
terminando esto porque la proyección
vamos a escribirlo así la proyección
sobre nuestro psuv espacio el
complemento ortogonal debe de cualquier
vector
x no es otra cosa más que un tercio
verdad este un tercio sacándolo hasta el
final de 111 que multiplica al vector
loops esto quedó bastante amplio
que multiplica al vector pero acostadito
111 muy bien y esto por supuesto es
multiplicarlo por equis y otra vez este
es de uno por tres y esta es de tres por
uno entonces
perdón lo puse al revés lo puse al revés
este es de 3 x 1 verdad
esta de aquí
esta de aquí déjenme también el tamaño
esta de aquí perdón es de 3 x 1 y esta
de aquí es de 1 x 3 verdad es el número
de renglones son 3 y de columnas es una
aquí el número de renglones es 1 pero
son tres columnas entonces me debe
quedar una matriz de tres por tres y esa
matriz es muy sencilla de calcular vamos
a tener aquí que la proyección sobre el
complemento ortogonal de x pues va a ser
un tercio va a ser un tercio que
multiplica y fíjense vamos a tener que
multiplicar este renglón que sólo tiene
un elemento por esta columna que sólo
tiene un elemento verdad y aquí va el 1
y de hecho si hacemos lo mismo con cada
uno de los otros me queda puros unos lo
mismo pasa si yo tengo este renglón que
es el 1 y lo voy multiplicando por cada
una de las columnas
eso me da que todos los elementos de
esta matriz son
uno sí bueno podría meter en un tercio
aquí para multiplicarlo pero eso solo me
va a complicar el asunto y finalmente
hay que multiplicar por nuestro vector x
así que vamos a repasar tantito ya que
habíamos pero bueno habíamos definido
este espacio vectorial vimos estas
propiedades y que le dimos la vuelta al
problema donde realmente ya no íbamos a
calcular la matriz de proyección sobre
el espacio vectorial b si no íbamos a
calcular la matriz de proyección pero
sobre el complemento ortogonal y después
a la identidad se le restamos para
obtener la que realmente nos interesa
entonces vamos a hacer eso
vamos a hacer eso vamos a tener aquí que
la proyección la proyección sobre el
espacio ve ya no sobre el complemento
ortogonal todo esto lo que hicimos fue
para el complemento ortogonal aquí ya
sobre el espacio b de x es una matriz b
que multiplica x y esa matriz b no es
otra cosa más que la matriz identidad
menos la matriz sé que es esta es la
matriz entonces podemos decir que b
es la identidad de tres por tres que es
la que tiene uno en la diagonal cero en
todos lados
menos un tercio de la matriz que tiene
puros 1 la matriz de 3 por 3 que tiene
puros unos y eso bueno en realidad lo
podríamos pensar como que que esté un
tercio lo podemos quitar y poner un
tercio en todos lados un tercio aquí un
tercio un tercio un tercio un tercio
y un tercio y esto pues simplemente
fíjense en la diagonal tenemos uno y le
vamos a restar un tercio muy bien
entonces en la diagonal si yo tengo tres
tercios y le quitó un tercio en la
diagonal vamos a tener dos tercios dos
tercios y dos tercios
muy bien ahora bien en los otros yo
tengo 0 y le voy a restar un tercio
entonces aquí sería menos un tercio
menos un tercio menos un tercio menos un
tercio menos un tercio
me falta este menos un tercio muy bien
entonces aquí ya es como pudimos
encontrar la matriz de transformación es
esencialmente hallando primero hace hace
que es la matriz tras de sí la matriz de
transformación déjenme ver dónde donde
lo note
seguramente donde definía ce pero bueno
se es la matriz de transformación pero
de la proyección sobre el complemento
ortogonal y aquí sabemos que la matriz
que me interesa era la identidad menos
esta matriz que obtuvimos aquí verdad
entonces esto simplemente nos llevó a
encontrar esta matriz que ya es la
matriz b la que nos interesaba
esencialmente y que de hecho podemos
creo que fue algo muy bonito todavía
podríamos reescribir esto de aquí
todavía podríamos reescribir esto de
aquí como un tercio verdad porque a
todos les puedo factorizar un tercio de
quien aquí en la diagonal son 22
2 y en el resto son menos 1 - 1 - 1 - 1
- 1 - 1 ok esto es una expresión incluso
mucho más agradable de quién es la
matriz de transformación ve de todos de
todas formas nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo